c'est ton anniversaire
non c'est
[Musique]
pas moi
des tripes
voilà regardez oh [__] en plus de ça
regardez ça comme ça
non mais je vois pas qui c'est qui
en scooter
vous assistez pas c'est tout ce que je
peux vous demander si c'était moi
j'arrive de bosser donc vous insistez
pas c'est pas moi
votre patron vous vous demandez votre
adresse
attention c'est chaud attention oh là là
oh non regardez ce que vous avez fait je
vais les revendre je vais les revendre
c'est pas grave
tu as goûtez-moi ça madame goûter moi ça
goûter moi ça goûter moi ça
Goûter Goûter Goûter
[Applaudissements]
alors comment elles sont non
vous si vous avez commandé des tripes je
mets dans la boîte aux lettres
tu t'envoises franchement je te vois
plus de fusion la gueule toi quoi
j'entends pas
je les mets dans la boîte aux lettres
[Applaudissements]
la télé c'est stère à la maison c'est
vous qui avez été tiré au sort
quelque chose
merci merci
[Musique]
on est bien
on peut passer à côté des choses simples
faudra le couper le téléphone ce soir
qu'on soit pas emmerdé
madame
vous allez faire les courses
la seule chose c'est qu'il faut que je
retourne à 6h chercher ma fille à
l'école
laissez-moi s'il vous plaît laissez-moi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tu sais pas où tu es là j'ai payé en
plus
j'ai payé au mec du camping
il m'a dit le emplacement numéro 8
encore une heure ou deux
maintenant jusqu'à présent on parle très
gentiment on peut parler autrement si
vous voulez
autrement comment ça
j'ai mal au crâne
vous êtes pas sympa on m'avait dit que
l'écorce était sympa mais oui
parce que là c'est qu'est-ce que c'est
dur par terre
je vais prendre pour moi je sors
moins de bruit s'il vous plaît j'arrive
pas à dormir
non non non non non
[Musique]
le code on va prendre monsieur machin
allez hop
oui bonjour dis donc c'est encore votre
chien qui a fait caca dans le dans
l'entrée là
tout le monde dit que c'est le vôtre
bon bah vous nettoyez où on le fait
ah bah vous pouvez le faire si ça vous
tente bon bah ouvrez on va on va
nettoyer mais bon faites attention quand
même
si
et hop allô oui on est en train de faire
des essais est-ce que vous m'entendez
oui mais
essayez voir d'appuyer sur le bouton
pour ouvrir la porte
[Musique]
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il fait froid
à l'appareil livraison de moules
marinières à domicile
bon mais moi je vous ai pas commandé des
moules pardon je vous ai pas commander
des moules en plus c'est super lourd
pensez-vous il y en a pour cette
d'accord c'est bien gentil madame
oui allô oui bonjour c'est pour qui veut
gagner des millions
[Applaudissements]
comment dit-on 7 et 3 font 11 ou 7 et 3
font 11
3 femmes
11 ans
[Musique]
on peut pas faire gagner des millions
comme ça
bonjour bonjour
de moins de 45 ans on se met dans la
cuisine
[Musique]
et le texte c'est
tartoche sur du pain c'est fastoche stop
c'est pas bon
[Musique]
manger de la crème
pourquoi vous crachez madame
s'il vous plaît
c'est pas vrai allez top
c'est face
à regarder vous prenez monsieur fastoche
pour un conte stop
[Musique]
c'est ton anniversaire
non c'est pas mon anniversaire quoi
bon je ferme parce que qu'est-ce qu'il y
a non non je ferme on n'est pas au vin
c'est le vin ici mais oui c'est
l'anniversaire de qui mais de toi
joyeux anniversaire
arrêtez tout de suite arrêtez tout de
suite
vous avez le droit de mettre des billets
si vous voulez
un petit coup pour la route
je vais pas avoir le temps il faut que
je travaille madame
bonjour
c'est lequel Raymond
c'est ton anniversaire allez viens
allez viens quoi
parce qu'il faut que je vous donne le
slip comme cadeau à la fin
un petit bisou bonsoir c'est Pascal
c'est même pour MTV il est 8h55 dans 5
minutes le match OM - Paris
Saint-Germain et comme j'ai pas de télé
comme d'habitude il fallait chez les
gens on est à Marseille on est où là à
Marseille à Marseille je suis avec cabel
et puis on va taper chez les gens on y
va
c'est bon c'est bon ça fait rien comme
ça il y a quelqu'un
bonsoir c'est Pascal selem pour MTV on
peut venir voir le match chez vous on va
regarder le match
vous connaissez Kamel l'humoriste
marseillais on peut venir il y a pas de
souci
c'est gentil
je crois que tu es en train de tomber
amoureux de moi
oh non pas lécher pas lécher c'est à
vous le chien madame
vous savez quoi
on va le tuer
6 mois excusez-moi je peux mettre les
pieds là
je suis désolé je veux pas mettre le
bordel
mais moi au moins j'enlève mes
chaussures
il y a que toi et moi je sais que les
odeurs pour les femmes enceintes c'est
très très fort s'il n'y a pas d'odeur
vous êtes sûr quand même
c'est quoi votre nom de famille
Attard le grand-père le petit-fils la
fille et le beau-fils
alors pas de gros mots alors le premier
qui dit un gros mot c'est une grande
claque
[Applaudissements]
c'est quoi la spécialité culinaire de
Marseille
il faut combien de temps pour faire une
bonne bouillabaisse
trois heures moi je vous donne 10
minutes moi
vous avez de la boîte
vous allez manger nous on n'a pas du
tout mangé
les pâtes
[Musique]
c'est possible
alors une un jus d'orange à la bière
parce qu'on a pas le droit à l'alcool et
moi un jus d'anis s'il vous plaît OK
et où est-ce qu'il cache son argent ton
papa
côté de l'ordinateur
dis-moi où dis-moi
en tout cas c'est la première fois qu'on
vient voir un match avec un couple
échangiste
pendant toute la soirée le match c'est
important je sais que c'est important
mais on est en train de trinquer
Sébastien tu trinques avec nous allez et
allez allez
c'est pas un chinoise et les Chinois
oui alors je tiens à vous dire que je
vous invite tous à mon spectacle qui
commencera le 9 novembre jusqu'au 21
novembre au quai du rire à Marseille mon
premier one man show qui s'appelle Léo
la caméra donc je vous serez mes invités
puisque vous avez eu la gentillesse nous
inviter ce soir avec Kamel pour regarder
le match
c'est 80 euros vous pouvez régler tout
de suite
dire que vous voulez pas vous mettre sur
le canapé ça me dérange de voir une
femme enceinte sur une chaise pourrie
tu sais tu t'es pas beaucoup trompé
Pascal regarde la maison
je rigole vous avez le droit de le taper
c'est quoi comme comme race ce chien
c'est quoi c'est un turbo diesel
le petit qui pèse depuis tout à l'heure
c'est le chien
bêtement comme ça pendant toute la
soirée
pourquoi son fils
très vite et c'est lui en vacances
la question parce que franchement je
tiendrai pas une semaine
ou quoi
[Musique]
l'amitié c'est ça vous recevez des gens
chez vous c'est minimum quoi déjà vous
nous recevez rien au bout d'un moment on
a chaud il veut prendre une douche c'est
gentils
mais d'où ça la serviette
je vous laisse la serviette c'est
laquelle
[Applaudissements]
mille la serviette allez allez
[Musique]
bon il y a pas grand chose
ça fait du bien
[Musique]
merci
[Applaudissements]
pourquoi sois pas
positif
Moon si c'est comme ça nous on s'en va
on a été bien gentil de accepter de
venir chez vous
[Musique]
dans les pâtes
[Applaudissements]
on a marqué
n'oublie pas que le petit faut l'appeler
Pascal
[Applaudissements]
merci infiniment au plaisir au plaisir
allez au revoir merci bien
allez viens allez et voilà rien Kamel
allez sois gentil
allez au revoir merci
c'est coincé la main dans votre boîte
aux lettres dis donc
impossible de retirer les dents
vous avez une trop petite fente
en plus j'ai pas terminé ma tournée moi
un truc à boire là parce que je me sens
tout fait je saigne
merde
[Musique]
c'est tentant belle forme comme ça là
vous avez pas du scotch du fil
comme j'ai des fils qu'est-ce que vous
voulez faire avec des filles merci
beaucoup madame
juste un petit contrôle de routine
parce qu'il y a une péniche qui a lâché
une caisse là
on fait toute la rue comme ça on est
bien obligé là c'est une péniche là qui
a lâché une caisse
justement c'est pas ça
oui ça fait un peu si on dirait une
odeur
de toute façon moi je dois partir alors
maintenant vous allez
comme je sais pas si on va pas mettre le
périmètre en quarantaine
[Musique]
pas pouvoir vous laisser sortir ça
et la moyenne c'est combien
6 6
prendre une douche
[Rires]
un suppo et Oli tu parles au-dessous
[Applaudissements]
des mesures de quoi attendez
cette mesure
[Musique]
que ça dépasse partout
qui est de votre côté quoi parce que
c'est à Lui bon
vous touchez pas
le voisin il dit que ça l'appartient
toutes les prunes
qui dit
mon boulot monsieur
vous le touchez pas là vous gardez les
les rien du tout vous coupez rien du
tout
vous ne coupez rien du tout cet arbre
est à nous deux merde alors
à qui nous deux
je comprends pas ce que votre démarche
vous m'emmerdez je serais toi je suis en
train de manger je vous dis de ne pas ne
pas intervenir vous êtes chez moi alors
je sais pas moi parce que qu'est-ce que
c'est que ce machin c'est quoi
l'embrouille avec votre voisin
vous avez le droit de rentrer chez moi
bien sûr non allez voir le gars allez le
voir vous moi je sais pas mon voisin
vous êtes chez moi si
je veux j'ai pas de jardin moi j'ai pas
dit mais moi je vous dis vous
n'intervenez pas chez moi et qu'est-ce
que c'est que cette histoire mais je
sais ça débarque comme ça là ça débarque
je sais pas c'est quoi le problème avec
votre voisin moi je sais pas moi
m'emmerdez je n'ai pas de problème avec
mon voisin aller voir le voisin pas de
contre moi c'est pas moi faute à moi si
vous êtes en bises avec nos voisins je
ne comprends pas votre démarche
merde alors
comment on fait pour la facture parce
que la facture est à votre frère
moi je vais prendre une trique à la fin
là une mais qu'est-ce que vous me
racontez de facture là maintenant voilà
allez allez virer là
je vends du lilas vous venez de cueillir
le lilas
et puis vous voulez me rendre
parce qu'il dépasse comment il dépend il
dépasse là
vous venez cueillir du lilas chez moi
avec une échelle pendant que je ne suis
pas là et maintenant vous voulez me le
vendre non mais alors vraiment
bon regardez un beau bouquet comme ça
donnez moi ça mais il y a pas que à vous
il y a celui-là
est parfait d'accord je peux en prendre
du blanc quand même non ça c'est du beau
gardez-le je vous fais la bise non non
allez allez un bisou non allez goûter le
camp
[Musique]